Okay, so we've done a little
bit of user research.
We've gotten our
feedback from our users.
And we've pulled out
the bits that are useful.
And we've just now talked about how to
bucket the feedback from multiple users.
The final step is to decide whether
we want to make another low fidelity
prototype or whether we want to move on
to making a medium fidelity prototype.
There are really two
deciding factors here.
First, did we get feedback that answers
the question we started out with?
Second, does the feedback overall say
that we're going in the right direction?
If the answer to both questions is yes,
we should make a higher
fidelity prototype.
If the answer to either question is no,
we should make another low fidelity
prototype, incorporating what
feedback we can from this one.
It's vital to note that the second
question is very subjective.
For some prototypers,
it's important to have 90%
positive feedback to feel like
you're going in the right direction.
For some,
you only need 50 percent positive.
So with all that in mind,
do you think it's better to move on
to medium fidelity prototypes, or
do you think it's better to do
another round of low fidelity first?